he is the most famous person on the
planet and the most divisive equally
loved it's equally abhorred it is
impossible not to have an opinion about
the brash Twitter loving 45th President
of the United States yet few people
truly understands what makes Trump Trump
by going back into his past we are able
to gain valuable insight into the vast
complexities that make up the man in
this week's by graphics we're looking at
the Donald before he took up residence
at 1600 Pennsylvania Avenue
[Music]
Donald John Trump was born on June the
14th in 1946 the fourth of five children
to Fred Trump and Mary McCloud Donald's
grandfather also nicknamed Frederick
migrators in 1885 from Germany he
brought with him a reputation as one of
the finest builders of his generation
Frederick helps to change the face of
Queens with his building projects they
primarily consisted of the construction
of solid though basic brick rental
apartments Fred followed his father's
path and became a prominent residential
developer by the time Donald was in his
teen years his father had amassed more
than 27,000 apartments in such Brooklyn
suburbs as Flatbush Sheepshead Bay
Bensonhurst and Brighton Beach he also
had extensive properties in the Queens
neighborhoods of Coney Island's and
Jamaica estates in addition to his
residential housing portfolio Fred moved
in to commercial developments during the
Depression years of the 30s he built
Trump markets which was a supermarkets
built on the concept of serve yourself
and save with war on the horizon he also
got into construction on military bases
Donald's mother Mary McLeod Trump was of
Scottish heritage she met Frank in the
early 1930s as a teenager when they were
married in 1936 she was just twenty four
years old they settled into a 23 room
house in Queens vows was extravagance
with a colonial style portico frame
entrance and six imposing white marble
pillars
Fred's two Cadillacs FCT one and FCT two
were parked in the driveway the Trump's
were one of the few families to have an
intercom system installed in their home
not to mention a chauffeur and a
personal Butler mrs. Trump was also a
philanthropist who became passionately
involved in a number of causes that were
close to her heart she was the main
driving force of the ladies helper of
Jamaica facility as well as the Jamaica
day care nursery Mary was also an ardent
supporter of the National Kidney
establishments of New York and the group
mainstreaming partners of incredible
Neck New York which provided help for
people who were crippled of all of his
children young Donald showed the most
interest in his father's business
ventures as a result Fred would
sometimes take the boy onto construction
sites with him as he developed his own
personality Donald gains a bit of a
reputation as a bully his parents were
lacks in imposing discipline upon him on
one occasion the trumps neighbor Martha
Burnham
came home to find the four year old
Donald throwing stones at her son Dennis
Donald had apparently targeted Dennis as
an easy mark for his venom
Martha warned her son to stay away from
the nasty Trump boy by the time he was 8
Donald was the leader of a group of
young thugs who would ride around Queens
on their bicycles yelling out insults to
be born and stopping to deal with other
youngsters who they didn't like the look
off he was known for saying whatever he
wanted and acting impulsively fred's
enrolled Donald's at a private education
facility in Forest Hills called Q Forest
School Fred happens to be on the board
of trustees for that school this fact
seems to have emboldened Donald's in his
wayward behaviors taking the lead
amongst a bunch of boys who were
constant troublemakers he would pull
girl's hair purposely bump into other
students desks and talk out of turn in
class
Donald's grades they were mediocre at
best this was mainly due though to lack
of application rather than lack of
ability a situation that greatly
frustrated his teachers however on the
playgrounds and the sports fields he
displayed considerable ability his
favorite gym game was dodgeball he
displayed great dexterity and avoiding
balls that were thrown at him and he was
often the last man standing outdoors he
excelled at baseball he was a talented
player and a fierce competitor as a
sixth grader his batting power was
exceptional when he came up to batter
the defending side would have to extend
its fielders way out in order to handle
his daunting right arm swing one morning
when he was 12 years old Donald and his
friend Peter Brandt jumped on the train
to Manhattan such an excursion had not
been authorized by Donald's parents
getting off at Fifth Avenue and 53rd
they spent the day strolling through
Central Park
buying curiosity is at novelty stores
and wandering among the homeless one of
the items that Donald purchased was a
switchblade knife it was months later
that Fred discovered the knife and the
story of Donald's unauthorized trip to
the city was uncovered Fred he was
outraged he finally came to the
realization that Donald was out of
control and that something had to be
done
Fred decided that his fourth son was in
dire need of some external discipline he
enrolled Donald at the Rosia military
boarding school about 70 miles away
there would be no more comfortable
living in the mansion and swirling
around the neighborhood Donald in
implementing this new strategy Fred
acted quickly not even giving his son
time to say
his fat wells
life was indeed vastly different at the
military school the boys were required
to wear a uniform that consisted of a
thick fleece pullover and pants an alarm
woke them up early in the morning and
their entire day was regulated by the
clock Donald's life was now completely
controlled by Theodore Tobias the
hands-on school administrator tobias was
a no-nonsense World War two veteran who
demanded excellence from his new
recruits
he knew that many of the boys that were
sent to him with their to be toughen up
and to have discipline imposed upon them
and he took that responsibility very
seriously as you might imagine all of
this was a pretty serious shot for
Donald his initial reaction was
resentments and a natural tendency to
buck the system he soon racked up a
number of charges including not making
his bed and not properly cleaning the
sink yes administrator Tobias saw
something else in the young Trump the
boy was incredibly driven and always had
a desire to be number one realizing the
bucking the system was only going to get
him in deeper trouble
Donald's began trying to follow the
rules the biggest improvement was with
regard to his personal orderliness here
on awards for the cleanliness of his
personal area indeed his orderliness
bordered on the obsessive winning him
the nickname mr. fastidious Donald's
loudmouth bluster quietened down as
discipline was injected into his system
he became soft-spoken and had an air of
self-confidence he developed friendships
despite often being regarded as a bit
cocky and bragging too much about his
father's wealth then during a senior
year donald was made a company captain
this put him in a position of oversight
over younger boys he inspected their
personal space and was responsible for
generally keeping them in order his
reputation was such that he very rarely
had to raise his voice at his charges a
simple step sometimes accompanied by a
raised eyebrow was enough to impart his
displeasure in his position as company
captain Trump proved himself to be an
effective delegator this develops to the
extent that he would give the job of
inspection of the boys under his
commands to others while he retired to
his room to recline on his bed this
practice soon came to the attention of
administrator Tobias who was less than
impressed
he removed Trump from his role as
company captain and gave him a school
administrative position instead Donald's
then went on to frame this as a
promotion for his stellar job in his pre
yes roll so following his graduation
from Rozier at the age of 18 he enrolled
at Fordham University in the Bronx
to study real estate he was determined
to follow in his father's footsteps and
enter the world of real estate
development of course he was going to do
it bigger and better than his old man
and to do that he figured he needed a
real estate degree in 1966 after two
years at Fordham Donald transferred to
the University of water business college
here he was out of place while coming
from a background of money he didn't
have the Ivy League breeding of those he
rubbed shoulders with he was rough and
obtuse and soon proved himself to be the
proverbial round hole in a landscape of
square pegs on his first day the
lecturer asked why every student there
had decided to study real estate when it
came to his turn
Donald stood up and declared that he was
going to become the king of New York
City when it came to the real estate
business
drum graduated from Wharton in 1968
returning to New York with a degree in
real estate at this time he was eligible
for the draft to serve his country in
Vietnam
however a September 1968 physical exam
resulted in a medical suspension due to
bone goads in his heels setting himself
up in an apartment in Queens Trump began
working for his father in early 1969
from very start he felt a deep-seated
need to prove to his father that he was
a supremely talented real estate man the
Trump way of doing business was called
into question in 1973 when a handful of
tenants took up a class-action lawsuit
against the company
claiming racial discrimination in
violation of the Fair Housing Act the
case was impossible to prove however and
the Trump Organization paid a small
settlement without any admission of
guilt around this same time Donald was
promoted to president of the company and
his first act was to rename the company
the former Elizabeth Trump and son
became the Trump Organization one of his
next moves was to hire aggressive
attorney Roy Cohn Cohen had a reputation
as a bulldog lawyer if anyone dared to
file a suit against those who he worked
for he would go out and destroy them
in 1975 Donald met Ivana Maria zalnitch
Kivar she was a beautiful sports skier
who hailed from Czechoslovakia a
remnants soon blossomed and after a
two-year courtship the couple were
married over the next five years Ivana
was given management responsibilities in
a number of business ventures she also
bought from three children Donald Jr
Ivanka and Eric
the vast majority of Fred Trump's
business was centered on middle-income
housing in Brooklyn Queens and Staten
Island - Donald's this was small-time he
wanted to break into the large-scale
commercial real estate in the heart of
the Big Apple he set his sights on a
project in Manhattan his target was the
Commodore hotel the Commodore was a
derelict mm room white elephants on 42nd
Street Trump intended to completely
remodel this into an upmarket Hyatt
Hotel the Hyatt Empire was run by the
Pritzker family despite having presences
all over the states they had no
representation in New York but the area
surrounding the Commodore was extremely
seedy in the Pritzker's were in need of
some serious convincing for Donald
however the seedy environment and the
decrepit state of the hotel meant that
he would be able to pick up the property
at a steal of a price to make the
purchase however he would need to borrow
a lot of money the finance was secured
by bank loans that were underwritten by
both Fred Trump and the Hyatt
organization
Donald also managed to secure a 40-year
tax exemption on the building the
renovation of the Commodore and its
metamorphosis into the Grand Hyatt Hotel
proved to be a great success with Trump
winning accolades from the city fathers
along with an award for the tasteful and
creative recycling of a distinguished
Hotel the grand hyatt project coupled
with the reflected reputation of his
father established Donald as a
legitimate player in the New York
commercial real estate market
shortly after the completion of the
Hyatt Project Trump began negotiations
to develop a 58 storey building on Fifth
Avenue adjacent to famous New York
landmark Tiffany & Company this 200
million dollar development was to be
Trump's masterpiece it would feature a
six story atrium that was lined with
pink marble and an 80-foot waterfall the
penthouse was to be Donald's personal
living quarters with his officers just
below the first couple of floors would
then feature some of the world's most
famous retailers the building opens in
1983 and was named Trump Tower it's
opening received international attention
and was attended by a number of
celebrities at the same time that Donald
was working on Trump Tower a local New
York builder was attempting to repair
derelict Woolman skate rink after two
and a half months the work had
stalemated there was a lot of public
dissatisfaction that the ring was not
reopened on time then Donald interjected
himself into the whole affair when he
wrote a letter to the mayor stating that
he could supercharge the project and
bring it in well under budget the mayor
responded by calling his bluff Donald
went straight to a concrete her that he
had a working relationship with he
convinced them to take the Wollman Rink
project on for free with the guarantee
that the publicity it would bring would
far outweigh the costs involved the
project went ahead on that basis and was
completed under time and under budget by
three-quarters of a million dollars the
publicity and public appreciation that
the Wolman ring project brought in was
huge but it was all directed toward
Donald Trump the contractor who had done
the heavy work without payments barely
even got a mention
[Music]
the early 1980s saw Trump moving into
the gambling business he acquired all of
the necessary licenses and then
purchased a property in Atlantic City to
do this project he partnered with the
holiday in cooperation the parent
company of Harrah's casinos in 1984 the
facility opened as Harrah's at Trump
Plaza the casino was a great success
wetting Trump's appetite for more he
actively sought our casinos that had
failed gambling licenses finding one in
the form of the Atlantic City Hilton
hotels casino he acquired the property
spending 310 million dollars on the
purchase and upgrade it later reopened
as Trump Castle always wanting to go one
better Trump took over developments of
the largest casino in the world at the
time the Taj Mahal the Trump Taj Mahal
opened in 1990 however Trump had to go
into extreme debt in order to open the
doors revenues would have to average a
million dollars per day in order to
cover costs this was simply an
unheard-of number and the reality was it
was never going to happen
Trump indeed had to go through major
bankruptcy restructuring in order to
keep the casino going eventually ending
up with just a 10% ownership stake
around this same time Trump also
established Trump's hotels and Casino
resort's which became a publicly traded
company throughout the 1980s and 1990s
Trump never let up on his real estate
developments despite his financial
problems in 1985 he purchased 76 acres
of western Manhattan in order to create
a television city complex then in 1988
he purchased the Plaza Hotel for 407
million dollars then 1989 saw his first
investment in Florida by this time he
had also acquired a number of golf
resorts across the country
in 1992 Trump hit the headlines for all
the wrong reasons when his affair with a
23 year old actress named Marla maples
was exposed despite rumors Ivana refused
to believe the truth until Marla
followed the trumps on a skiing trip and
confronted Ivana with the news that
Donald was in love with her and that
Ivana best give up on him this was too
much for Ivana she filed for divorce
leaving maples free to marry Donald
which she did in 1993 they had one child
together who they named Tiffany after
the famous New York department store the
marriage though it was rocky from the
start and ended in divorce in 1999
ironically the proceedings were
instigated by Donald when he learned
that his wife was having an affair
Donald was then associated with a number
of women in the early 2000s back in 1998
he had met a Slovenian Beauty by the
name of Melania canals over the next few
years their relationship develops at the
point where Melania became Donald's
constant companion they were engaged in
2004 and married on January the 22nd
2005 in Palm Beach Florida
the couple's only child Baron William
Trump was born on March the 20th 2006 on
October the 21st Trump hotels casinos
and resorts restructured its debt
resulting in Trump's ownership of the
company dropping from 59 to 27% the
company applied for bankruptcy
re-emerged as Trump Entertainment
Resorts
Holdings Trump now put a premium on
pushing his brands with the Trump logo
being placed on all manner of products
even released his own game Donald
Trump's real estate tycoon Trump's
political views they've undergone a
metamorphosis over the years up until
1987 he was a Democrat however in that
year he registered for the first time as
a Republican toying with the idea of
running for office he placed full-page
ads in three papers espousing his views
which were that America needed to stop
propping up other countries and start
looking after its own people in October
of 1999 Trump established an exploratory
panel to assess the viability of his
running for the Reform party's candidate
for presidential nominee in 2000 it was
decided that his lack of profile on the
West Coast would be too much of a
detriment this led him to pass on the
opportunity from that point onwards
however he bided his time and
increasingly made political comment for
public consumption
[Music]
in 2003 Trump ventured into the world of
reality television when he became the
executive producer and star of The
Apprentice the show in which contenders
go through a series of challenges to win
a job as Trump's apprentice was a huge
success
it propelled Donald Trump to worldwide
recognition status and won in a star on
Hollywood's Walk of Fame
Trump re-entered the political arena in
2001 when he raised questions about the
legitimacy of President Barack Obama's
birth certificate he doggedly held to
this view
despite Obama's insistence that he was
born on US soil he seriously considered
running for the top office again in 2012
but again decided that the time wasn't
right then on June the 16th 2015 he
famously announced from Trump Plaza that
he would be throwing his hat into the
ring for the Republican nomination for
president in 2016
few people took him seriously but
serious he was and history will record
him for better or worse as the 45th
President of the United States so I
really hope you enjoyed that episode of
biographic if you did there's a couple
of things you could do right now one is
hit that like button below also if you
want more stuff like this we put out
brand new videos every Monday and every
Thursday so hit that subscribe button
below and subscribe button doesn't do
what it used to on YouTube if you
actually want to get a notification
about these videos please do hit that
Bell button next to the subscribe button
and that'll send you a notification
every time every Monday and Thursday
won't put out a new video also if you
want to watch something else right now
stuff from the archive over there on the
right and as always thank you for
watching